welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid so I've noticed lately I've had a
lot of energy it's just bursting to get
out of me and that got me thinking what
is energy I mean what is it really the
main problem here stems from our limited
ability to define things in our language
so to deal with this problem I started
with the online etymology dictionary to
find the origin of the word itself which
turned out to be ancient Greek for at
work suggesting only what I already knew
energy gives us the ability to do stuff
in fact all the definitions and all the
dictionaries and science books seem to
have the same issue they tell us what
energy does and not what energy is what
is it we really only have two ways of
understanding things first we could
compare and contrast with something we
already understand or second we could
divide it into parts
and categorize them unfortunately energy
is unlike anything we've ever seen
before and it doesn't seem to have any
parts whatsoever which leaves us in a
bit of a pickle hmm wait it does look
different when it's in different places
what you've never seen energy before
that's because you're using your eyes
you've got to use your mind's eye go
find your imagination and dust it off
got it okay cool
if we can find out all the places it can
be then maybe we'll have a better idea
of what it is can we make a list
definitely I love lists we've seen stuff
nearby other stuff we'll call that
potential energy we've seen stuff moving
and call that kinetic energy we felt
stuff be really warm we can call that
thermal energy we've seen stuff shine
and call that light energy I guess and
stuff explodes too which has to do with
chemical and nuclear energy oh and life
is a thing I mean our bodies are just
chemical energy machines right you know
what might be even better than a list a
concept tree okay let's see we disappear
over there and voila it's a lot of
different energies there's no way the
universe is really that complicated and
what the heck is this stuff anyway
internal energy is the energy inside
stuff so that must have to do with the
molecules making up the stuff we need to
imagine a little smaller molecules move
spin and wiggle
just kinetic energy they do have a
tendency to stay together but bounce off
of each other when they get too close
that's potential energy chemical energy
is what holds the atoms together in a
molecule
again that's potential energy and
nuclear energy is holding the atomic
nucleus together so that's just
potential energy - okay this is looking
a lot better everything just seems to be
potential energy kinetic energy or mass
so what's mass that's not a simple
question answer fully but the short
version is that it depends on how you're
looking at the stuff in question if
you're so close that you can see the
quarks inside the protons then it
doesn't look like there's a whole lot of
mass there but if we zoom out all of
that stuff just looks like a single
proton all that potential energy holding
the quarks together looks like mass
because we really can't see it anymore
the point is that almost all the energy
we call mass it's just the potential
energy inside the nuclei of the atoms
you're mostly just empty space so in the
end all energy is really just potential
energy and kinetic energy some of it
just happens to be in the tiny nooks and
crannies inside things this hasn't
really answered our question yet no I
guess it doesn't huh on top of that
kinetic energy is kind of weird I mean
the driver of a car has kinetic energy
right well what if you're a passenger in
that same car as far as you're concerned
the driver is sitting still no no the
earth is stationary and we're both
moving the earth is stationary what
about it rotating once a day are going
around the Sun once a year or zipping
around the center of the galaxy with the
Sun so yeah this leaves us with an
unfortunate truth we don't really know
what energy is every hypothesis we've
ever had that has pretended it's some
kind of substance has epically failed it
seems to only be this weird abstract
property of the universe energy is just
a number and the total amount never
changes so what do you do when you have
a lot of energy
wink-wink nudge-nudge please share in
the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you